this is the portrait of a veteran this
is the portrait of a man who's ready to
do whatever his country has
this is the portrait of a veteran who
would fight again if he could no he
wasn't wounded
it wasn't an enemy shot that crippled
him it's not a wounded battle that makes
him walk this way yet this soldier was
crippled by the war he was one of the
tens of thousands of men were mobilized
away from home away from friends away
from old habits he was struck by an
enemy in the blood by a germ the
spirochete the germ that causes syphilis
syphilis that came and seemed to go away
but stayed in the blood did [ __ ] him
later on this is the portrait of the
veteran of World War one a portrait of
one of the thousands of soldiers taken
from duty by syphilis one of the
thousands crippled some killed by the
enemy in the blood but this is a
sickness and a death that is preventable
syphilis can be fought and beaten and in
the laboratory they are fighting it in
the laboratory they found new and
powerful weapons against syphilis
there's the microscope test that
searches out the spirochete and helps
the doctor find the early infection
there's the blood test that can search
the blood for syphilis doctor send blood
samples here for laboratory testing
the technician examines the blood and
finds negative this patient is not
infected
negative
this patient is not infected
positive danger this patient may have
syphilis and the doctor examines him for
other signs and does a second blood test
to check the first if the patient is
infected and it can be treated the
infection can be thought with the
weapons of the laboratory and the
infection can be conquered if a patient
takes the full course of treatment the
laboratory is found the chemicals that
cure syphilis bismuth mercury and
arsenic early treatment with these
chemicals is insurance against a child
born dead or crippled insurance against
a heart weakened by syphilis here's the
battle in the laboratory as well thought
but this is only half the pipe here is
where the other half of the plate must
be made here in the schools and colleges
here where syphilis strikes at the
fighting strength of the country in the
Navy and among the soldiers here we must
fight and in the mills and plants where
the nation's work is done
here where the people are this is where
venereal disease strikes and this is
where the other half of the fight must
be fought it can only be fought here
among the people and by the people by
people who know the enemy how he strikes
and how to strike back know the
dangerous part of the city the places
where the disease begins
places that infect the city and infect
its people the places were the easy
pickups yes these are the danger spots
the places that breed syphilis no the
other danger spots a dark the hidden
streets the places that are whispered
about these are the danger spots here
the disease begins yes here it begins
here a new chain of infection starts a
chain of infection that will take lives
of children to be born and bring people
to hospitals to insanity and of
blindness here it begins and spreads
from one part of the city to another
from one person to many people one
infected person carrying infection to
many people the infections spreading
from them and countless others
and with a disease come the quacks the
charlatans who thrive wherever people
are ignorant who bring disaster wherever
people have failed to fight syphilis the
quacks who promised cures but never cure
don't worry kid I can cure you it's no
worse than a bad cold out clear it up
for you here drink this
cure is guaranteed 30 years as
specialists in men's diseases dollar a
bottle it's cheap kid you can't go wrong
with this stuff you can't go wrong you
can't go wrong you can't go wrong
but he can go wrong he will go wrong
unless the people fight with knowledge
with treatment with blood tests to
search the enemy of yes the people must
fight to guard against the blindness
that syphilis may cause to prevent the
insanity the disease can bring prevent
the crippling but broken Minds the
twisted limbs the suffering in a poverty
all these the people must fight and the
fight must be swift and hard because
every day the casualties mouth
thousands of sick an idle and important
jobs are left undone production is
sabotage by syphilis
and men already under arms are struck by
the disease 1917 the army lost seven
million days from active duty syphilis
is the sniper The Saboteur behind the
lines but it strikes not in the field
not in the camps but in the towns that
is where syphilis must be fought
so if the people learn they'll go to the
doctors in the clinics to find the
skills that will make them safe if each
person will guard himself he can help
destroy this waster of America he can
save his own in the nation strength or
production but a nation secured for all
the work and joy of living
the people can raise this shadow from
the land from their homes if the people
learn if they fight syphilis